let's go to 9 1 9 yang guy who is voting
for Biden 909 yang guy voting for Biden
does that does that ring a bell yeah it
does a David how you doing hey how are
you I'm doing all right
I just want to know what you think is
the best way for us to make some
positive change as progressives under
the Biden administration beautiful okay
excellent so let's imagine November 3rd
assuming we know the results on November
3rd we may not
November 3rd Donald Trump is removed it
is the end of an error and the start of
starting to the start of fixing the
reputation and infrastructure and
governmental functioning of the United
States with the election of Joe Biden ok
very optimistic scenario that moment the
David Pakman show becomes a show not
about removing Trump but about making
Biden the most progressive that we
possibly can so the question is a
beautiful question so as soon as this
happens we have to put pressure on Biden
to actually do the executive orders that
he has said he would do when he gets
elected president every one of the
changes he's promised to healthcare we
need to push for immediately and then
push for more in the midterms of 2022 we
need to make the House and hopefully the
Senate as left as we possibly can I mean
it's like the way I see it is when if
and when Joe Biden replaces Donald Trump
that's not the end that's the start when
it comes to the progressive movement
which has been playing defense for a
long time now because of Donald Trump we
get we haven't had the ball yet right
Ahmet so it's like imagine a football
game were we could potentially get the
ball back in November we've got to then
start calling the right plays to use a
sports metaphor okay yeah that would
start great cuz I'm thinking about like
as far as everyone start but by VP pick
and I think that the best one to get
some progress
change at this point would be Elizabeth
Warren and I just wonder if when we do
put the Senate and everything we do have
the ball if you know the politicians and
us will be able to actually get stuff
done as opposed to like returning to the
Obama years well that's going to be up
to us that's going to be up to us it's
going to be up to who we elect at the
state level who we put in place in the
Senate and in the House of
Representatives so the fight will
hopefully begin on January 21st
let's alright my friend thanks for the
call very much appreciate it
that's a Yank guy who has decided that
he must vote for Joe Biden that that is
the right thing to do let's go next to
our caller from the nine seven eight
area code caller from nine seven eight
what's your name and where are you
calling from
I'm calling from westminster
massachusetts westminster where is that
i we are in central mass for like twenty
thirty minutes away from western
depending out faster rather than all
right i would have imagined that was the
508 area code out there no no no we're
like a little farm town all right what's
going on um well i just wanted to know
what your take was on the recent
conflicts that been bubbling over with
china and india alongside the bombing of
the diplomat center and the dmz and if
you think that there is a plausible
scenario where we might blunder into
another global military conflict you
know i this could be me being naive but
I I actually feel pretty confident that
it is not going to blow over into a
major conflict the likes of which you're
suggesting but I do think that you know
we can't control who's in power in China
or in India nor should we but yeah I
would feel better if we had someone with
a steadier hand running the United
States than Donald Trump and obviously
there's going to be a lot that happens
before Joe Biden could even possibly be
sworn in if he were to win in November
so I am hopefully not naively confident
that this is not going to blow up but I
would feel better if we had I mean
listen you can
say a lot of things about Joe Biden he's
not super progressive do we need another
78 year old you know all this stuff
Joe Biden in terms of diplomacy and
knowledge of China and India blows Trump
at of the water by a hundred times we
may not agree with all of Joe Biden's
conclusions but I think Biden's
instincts would would be the right ones
when it comes to that region in
preventing this type of conflict he may
not do what we like on trade I mean I'm
not saying Biden's great on China period
but he's a steadier hand and he's a
diplomat and I would feel better having
him in the mix than Donald Trump
right I agree I one of the major
concerns that I had with this like and
its entirety was that you know all the
you know progress that president now
made with you know actually trying to
bring more of like a you know economic
flourishing to North Korea and all the
sudden all that for like him you know
even it's just the optics of this and
walking over past the DMZ into North
Korea for like the first for the first
time in like now they're pretty much
saying no screw that
we don't you know we didn't get what we
wanted now I feel like Trump's ego is
going to get ahead of well listen from
the get-go
all of these right-wingers who were
saying you know people are making fun of
Trump but he knows what he's doing when
it comes to set of North Korea he's
gotten concessions and he's made more
progress than this that only someone who
completely misunderstands or doesn't
know the history of relations with North
Korea could have imagined that Trump was
actually you know exhibiting a being
party to some major breakthrough with
North Korea and obviously that in the
last two years that's been proven to be
the case so yeah I mean if you're
waiting around for Trump to be the guy
that solves that situation it's
obviously not going to be him
yeah of course all right my friend thank
you so much appreciate the question
great to hear from you let's take a
quick break but if you're holding don't
hang up unless you want to get off the
phone because I am going to be going
right back to the phones after this
short break